listen andy is uh here with us now lisa
good morning thank you very much indeed
for joining us on the programme this
morning and we'll talk about your new
job in just a second um could christmas
be ruined i really hope not i mean like
every family around the country i
desperately hope not but i think largely
this is now in the government's gift the
vast majority of people as far as i can
see are doing what is being asked of
them wearing masks getting the booster
jab social distancing
you know my my little boy school has got
its doors and windows open trying to you
know increase ventilation even in the
cold people are people are trying their
best but there are some big holes in the
government's plans particularly around
travel
and the experience of coming back
somebody who's just served a shadow
foreign secretary i know this well and
taking a day to pcr test is very
shambolic for a lot of people the
government isn't even checking up on the
majority of those tests and whether
people are getting them or not and many
of the companies that are supposed to
provide them they don't even turn up
people don't get the results there are
there are big problems here and we need
the government to step up and do their
parts because we're doing ours
we've heard from nicolas sturgeon she
wants us to self-isolate for eight days
and then take a pcr test if we've
traveled overseas i think the bigger
issue actually is something that yvette
cooper who is our newly appointed shadow
home secretary has been saying as chair
of the home affairs select committee for
some time why aren't we taking asking
people to take pre-departure tests at
the moment people are getting onto
planes they're flying back into britain
from many countries with very high rates
of covid where there may be an omicron
variant they're then getting off the
plane and traveling home on public
transport where they're then asked to
take a pcr test and self-isolate that
does leave a great big hole in our
defenses and we've raised this
repeatedly with the government for 18
months and yet nothing has been done we
can't keep making the same mistakes over
and over again this is how we get the
situation where yet again we're debating
whether christmas is going to be ruined
or not
the omicron variant there might not be
any cause for concern so i spoke to
jenny harris the deputy chief medical
officer on saturday evening
and i think it's fair to say that we
just don't quite know enough about it
yet the you know how much the booster
jab the jab actually works in relation
to omicron you know how how
transmissible it is these are all things
that the scientists are working around
the clock to try and work out what we do
know right now though is that the
biggest variant in the uk the most
prevalent variant is the delta variant
the one that we've we've been dealing
with already we know that the vaccine is
effective against the delta variant so i
think the message from all of us across
the political spectrum putting aside our
differences
is please go and get the vaccine please
go and get your boosted job because that
will make a big difference to the
national effort three more cases i'm
just being told have been found in
scotland um not sure about you know
what happened for them to
be
covered positive but it isn't
necessarily a south africa vaccine
south africa covid variant is it that's
one of the challenges i think that's we
don't know where it's come from i think
that's right and actually what we do
know is that countries that are better
at detecting these things that have
better genomic sequencing in in country
are the ones that are most likely to
find it so it may be possible just as
with the so-called kent variant it's
it's likely that that didn't emerge in
kent it was traced in the uk because
we've got some of the best scientists in
the world and scientific facilities so
it is a problem because by the time you
discover these things you don't know how
far they've traveled but i've been
amazed actually having met with the
scientists that are working on this all
over the world but particularly here in
the uk how sophisticated they are about
tracking these things the first two
cases that were found they were able to
track very very quickly
how they'd come into the uk how those
cases were connected i'm sure they'll be
working on this now and i think there's
no reason for people to panic just do
the right thing follow the guidelines
try and be sensible and let's get
through this like we have done for the
last 18 months let's get through this
together one of the things the
government is doing and i'm sure you'll
applaud them for it is three and a half
million boosters or vaccinations or and
boosters a week is what they're aiming
for and they're hoping to mobilize an
army of volunteers and nhs staff
where does that then leave us with your
old hat on for giving vaccines to other
countries well we've got enough vaccines
to to make sure that the adult
population around the world is
vaccinated why don't we give it to you
well when i came here six months ago
that was the challenge it was the
challenge was to ramp up manufacturing
so that we weren't choosing between
vaccinating people in wigan and
vaccinating people in wuhan that's not
the challenge anymore the challenges the
first time you said that is it no
but the challenge is to get i get wigan
into everything yeah okay yeah i
appreciate it
but we you know the challenge is to get
them out to people across the world and
one of the problems they've had in south
africa and particularly many of the
surrounding countries
is that the healthcare infrastructure
needs to be there the vaccinations have
to arrive quickly enough many of them
arrive just as they're about to expire
so they simply don't have time to get
them into people's arms that's why we've
been critical of the government cutting
aid in the middle of a pandemic because
unless we defeat this virus everywhere
we're not going to defeat it everywhere
and the events of the last few weeks and
the emergence of omicron show exactly
why that matters to people here in
britain as well as to people around the
world now tell us about your new job
it's a new role it's i mean it's a it's
a it's a department that was created for
michael gove yeah in order to make good
on the prime minister's promise at the
29. there's no shadow with with labour
until now so right so that you we we've
had various people shadowing the same
brief and what we've done this time is
bring
all of that together into this super
department to really take on the tories
on this agenda we've had 11 years of
broken promises seven years of promises
on northern powerhouse rail that we just
ditched last week
and i am determined to make sure that
finally after a long time of people
clamoring for change that when people
look to national politics they will see
a politician and a political party that
is as ambitious for this country as the
people in it and has a plan to match
that's my job that's what i've been
tasked with by kirsten i think you can
probably see i couldn't be more pleased
about it
labour only ever wins an election when
they're center-right are you moving to
the center right i mean we're moving
north
left right you can keep that debate
we're going out into the country and
we're going to start delivering for
people in towns and villages and cities
that have been completely and utterly
abandoned by the political system you go
to grimsby you go to barnsley you go to
aberdeen you will find proud communities
who have a contribution to make but so
often they're held back not by the
skills of their young people not by the
abilities in those communities not by
their own ambition but by a national
government that isn't investing in the
infrastructure that would bring good
jobs and start to bring the spending
power back so that young people don't
have to get out to get on and we can
rebuild our high streets and our
communities that's the agenda that will
be the battleground for not just the
next election but for the future of this
country and i am determined that we are
going to deliver on it yeah so kyocerma
has you know been slowly but surely
getting rid of the left in his um shadow
cabinet where does angela reina fit in
this night well i mean i you know i
didn't even tell her that it was
happening i would say to you first of
all i am the left i mean you know we're
all the left we the labour are
progressives and you know we have
differences
sure but i mean look look we have
differences of opinion
too often that's seen as a problem i
don't think it is and in the last 18
months i've seen angela rayner who's our
deputy leader who is an incredibly
strong woman with her own opinions
showing real authority and leadership in
her role and i've seen a leader in
kiestama who's completely comfortable
with that i can tell you from personal
experience he is not worried about being
around strong northern women who have
their own opinions and that's not having
a choice as far as she's concerned
because she he doesn't decide whether
she's in that role or not one wonders
why he didn't let her know what was
going on well she was elected with her
own mandate that's certainly true but i
think there's been a huge effort on both
of their parts to work together
and to embrace the differences that they
have you can see that they come from
very different backgrounds very
different traditions very different
parts of the country my view is that's
good for labour and you know as far as
reshuffles are concerned i've been
through a lot in the last 11 years most
of them didn't end as well for me as
this one and i've never seen a leader
who has um held back from doing what he
has so far always been he because it's
been common
as far as as far as i know i haven't
spoken to angela but as far as i
understand it he did let her know i
don't know to the extent not to the
extent that you know he was going to do
what he was being sacked but at the end
of the day kay kier
he's our candidate for prime minister
and the gaffer picks the team that's
right that's how it ought to be and i'm
just really pleased that he's
allowed me to get out into the country
so that i can start to stand up for the
people that haven't had a voice in this
system for far too long uh in the
absence of the shadow foreign secretary
who is david lammy now i think talk to
me about what's happening with
afghanistan because it breaks my heart
when i think about some of those people
that we left behind well i suspect that
you'll hear something from david lammy
on afghanistan today because it's an
absolute passion for him when you look
at those boats coming across the channel
one of the boats the boat that sank
recently there was an afghan soldier on
that boat who had said he'd simply given
up hope of a safe legal route opening up
and britain making good on its promise
to protect and support people like him
we will not stop fighting for the people
of afghanistan who helped us over two
decades our soldiers flew into danger in
order to support those people they they
stood with them for two decades so we're
not just making good on our promise to
the afghan people we're making good on
the promise to our armed forces who
fought for the future of afghanistan for
20 years i'm now responsible for afghan
resettlement and i can tell you that
i'll be working with labour councils and
labour mayors around this country to
make sure that we give a warm welcome to
those people when they reach the uk and
david will continue to fight the fight
to make sure that we make good on our
obligations if global britain is to mean
anything it means we stand with the
people who supported us over two decades
listen andy it's always good to talk to
you thank you very much for joining us
thank you